andipal poutine donne une arme à feu oeufs de pâques du château
piles sur l'approvisionnement de certaines entreprises
sont tenus une offre un dé
Je ne quitterai pas cet Astana que j'ai décollé
arrêt à l'entrée de la maison et au calme
site oui oser myna olga dormir
en fait 143 option kamsky et ici
les extrémités de sulfure jettent de la lumière lorsqu'elles
les manigances nous lièvres
poutine déshydraté donc il gasanova pas
offrez-vous des centimes et des taupes de s parfaits
site de vernis gel rappelez-vous
quant au figurant vous
mentionné qu'il n'avait pas été condamné pour son
l'activité politique et
infraction pénale contre
partenaires étrangers
concernant
aucune activité politique
devrait être couvert par des politiques
activités commerciales
projets, notamment en violation de la loi
ceci est la première partie de 2 en ce qui concerne
opposition non systémique en général
Je ne vois rien dans Western
suffisamment de pays d'Europe et des États-Unis
rappelez-vous le mouvement d'occupation de wall street
ou les mouvements des gilets jaunes en france
afin que ces personnes soient particulièrement soutenues
quand vous les déplacez disons dans
autorités représentatives dans
y compris le parlement quelque chose comme ça, nous ne le faisons pas
on voit d'ailleurs quand les gens sont entrés
congrès après les fameuses élections américaines
après cela avec des revendications politiques
plus de 6 poursuites pénales ont été engagées contre eux
affaires et
selon les accusations portées contre eux
menacer
longues peines de prison de
15 à 20 25 ans et peut-être plus
je te demanderais d'être
assez objectif
attention de ce coté
problèmes